Central Intelligence stars Dwayne
Johnson and Kevin Hardin comes to us
from the director of movies like we're
the Millers and dodge ball Kevin Hart
plays an accountant in this film who 20
years ago was voted most likely to
succeed he was the most popular person
in all of his high school much
differently than Dwayne Johnson's
character who was the most made fun of
person in his entire high school these
two come together 20 years later in the
middle of this strange CIA situation in
which somebody has stolen something and
somebody has to find out if someone's
corrupt or not or maybe that other guy's
corrupt or maybe she's corrupt who's
corrupt no one knows Dwayne Johnson is a
very tall man in Kevin Hartz a very
short man they're they're teaming up
that's really all you have to know
similar to finding dory this weekend I
didn't really have much anticipation for
this movie I like both the stars I think
Kevin Hart is hilarious when he is at
his best he is an amazing stand-up
comedian and truly really funny and
Dwayne Johnson I've liked for a long
time and to see them come together was
actually the best part of this movie
they work really well together the rock
plays a bit against type in this film
he's slightly action heavy while also
being more effeminate it was very
interesting to see and Kevin Hart is
also playing a bit against type you get
a lot of the normal Kevin Hart outbursts
and screaming and high-pitched voices
and of course he makes a lot of jokes
about his height but he also is in a way
almost the straight man of the two which
was very different to see and so it was
kind of cool to see both of them play
against type even though sometimes they
do revert back to their Kevin Hart isms
and they're doing the rock Johnson isms
they're by far the best part of this
movie it actually does have a lot of
good jokes it's also far better directed
than I expected it to be there are a lot
of action sequences and the close
quarters combat not so great a lot of
up-close stuff not very
realistic-looking and it was very blurry
and that was disappointing but the
chases the car chases the running chases
and some of the gun fights were done
really well I was actually impressed
with it where the movie fell apart for
me is whenever it tries to have a
political intrigue story to tell one guy
is supposed to be code named black
badger and someone else is supposed to
be code named black badger but wait
there's a flashback in which this guy
was codenamed black badger and then
somebody says he's honey badger but that
was just a joke and he's not really
a badger of any kind but rest assured
you're going to hear the word badger
17,000 times in this movie characters
keep coming on screen to try to explain
the story but it gets so convoluted and
overly serious that it wastes the comedy
in the film down and then the film ends
about seven different times and there's
a big message about bullying which I do
think is very important but it's handled
in the most cliched way that you could
possibly imagine really oh no this movie
was a lot better than I thought it was
going to be though Kevin Hart and Dwayne
Johnson work magic together they're
easily the best part of this movie I
could see a franchise with them as long
as they remove that stupid political
this movie doesn't need just
kept weighing the movie down I'm gonna
give central intelligence of b-minus
next week is going to be busy there are
reviews for a free state of Jones the
neon demon Independence Day resurgence
and the shallows as well as a review
coming for you on Sunday of Jaws 3-d and
coming up very soon
jaws tubes I'm going to fill in those
gaps it's going to be fun you guys are
the best as always thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
you